Welcome back to OUTFRONT, where we are
following the breaking news.
The judge in Fulton County
rejecting Mark Meadows
bid to move his case to federal court
ruling that Meadows actions
to help Trump overturn
the election were not connected
to his official duties
as White House chief of staff.
And many legal experts
say that if Meadows
failed to move his case
out of Fulton County,
it's bad news
for his other 18 co-defendants,
including Donald Trump.
OUTFRONT now, the Fulton County Sheriff,
Patrick Labat.
This is his first interview
since former President
Trump was arrested
and processed at the Fulton County Jail.
Which sheriff Labat runs?
Jeff, I really appreciate your time.
Thank you so much
for being with me tonight.
So you've got this breaking news.
The judge
saying the trial for Mark Meadows
is going to stay in your county,
which could be a sign
that a lot of other cases
are going to stay in your county,
including that for the former
president himself.
Bonnie Willis,
the D.A.,
says she wants to hold a joint trial
for all of them starting next month.
She says it'd be for months.
The judge said it could
easily be as many as eight.
We all saw your security preparations.
How tight
and how involved, how intensive
and exhausting
they were for the one day
Trump surrendered.
How do you sustain that for
maybe eight months?
Well, first,
I'm very proud of the women and men
for the county sheriff's office,
as well as the many
local and state partners
that really jumped in to help.
It was very well thought out plan.
And to your point,
it will be we'll create a rotation
to help sustain
something of that magnitude.
We have here in Fulton County a little
a little expertize
in working with these situations.
We've had large trials before.
Nothing of this magnitude
in terms of the status,
but we certainly
will live up to the opportunity
to show how well Fulton County
and the sheriff's office present Right.
Right.
I mean, because that would be you know,
that's running a marathon.
It's not a sprint, as you say.
That would be day in and day out
for months and months.
Of course,
you were there,
Sheriff, of former
President Trump's entire booking process.
You know,
you and I had spoken before
and you were adamant
that Trump would be treated
like any other defendant.
And you did that.
That included his mug shot
as something that had not incurred in
his other indictments.
You were there with him in your jail.
What was that like for you?
How would you
how could you describe his demeanor
as he was being booked?
Well, I will tell you, having
having been
in law enforcement for 32 years,
having been in a jail environment
equally as long.
It was eerily quiet
when you have that
many security protocols in place.
I will tell you, he came out
he was very stoic,
really, really in a space
that he was able to
really lean on what we were doing,
what we planned.
And so we took his mug
shot, took his fingerprints
as we would anybody else.
And ultimately
we arrange for his bond paperwork
to be brought to the motorcade
so that we could get him in and off
the premises as quickly as possible.
It's interesting
when you describe his demeanor
as stoic, that it was eerily silent
when you went through all that,
the mug shot, the fingerprinting,
did he say anything?
Did he have any
conversation or was he silent
No, he was pretty silent.
We spoke.
I came, gave very clear instructions.
He took the mug shot
and like anybody else, took
his fingerprints
and again,
he was in and out pretty quickly
and had no issue with any of it.
I mean, not that he could have,
but I mean, he was
in terms of his face, as you say,
it was just it was stoic.
There was no expression.
Now, it was, again, eerily silent.
And really, it was for me
on a personal level,
it was heartbreaking to see
someone of that stature
and who represents our country
in that fashion
having to go through this.
But again,
women and men of the Fulton
County Sheriff's Office, both our sworn
and professional team,
very, very, very professional
and making sure that we follow through
not only with our commitment
to serve our community,
but really focus on the job at hand and
and get the former president out.
It's interesting how you describe it.
It's heartbreaking
because it's, I think, important
for people
to remember
that it should be
for everybody, everybody in this country.
Trump did, of course, when he walked out,
he grabbed that mug shot and ran with it.
Proverbially
said he raised $7 million
in just a few days.
He put out
T-shirts and coffee mugs with the image.
Right. He owned it.
He owned it.
And he used it to raise a lot of money.
And then he said this about it
I think the fake indictment
that they did in
Georgia was very helpful.
And then they insisted on a mug shot
and somehow
it turned out to be a very iconic
sheriff.
In retrospect,
do you think that it was a mistake
at all?
Do you have any regrets
about doing the mug shot?
You know,
given that he, of course,
has capitalized off it in a massively
lucrative way?
Well, if
there were any regrets,
the copywriting,
I leave that up to the lawyers.
There is still an opportunity for us to
hopefully partake
in some of the capitalization of that
and then put it back
in the sheriff's office.
We don't know.
We'll leave that up
to the legal legal beagles,
if you will, to make sure that they
really are that keep around here as well.
So we are focusing on, again,
our making sure we maintain
as safe as possible facility
we can as well as again, I understand
the capitalization of it.
And maybe that was the plan all along.
We don't know.
But we're in a place
to maintain our commitment,
make sure we focus on
treating everybody's humanely as we can.
All right.
And to that point, Sheriff,
I do want to ask you about,
of course, a lot of the news
out there about your facility
when you talk about, you know,
treating people as safely as possible.
Trump has obviously attacked
your jail conditions there.
One of the fundraising emails,
he said in part,
while I was being arrested,
I got a firsthand look at the poor
and disgraceful conditions of the Fulton
County Jail.
It's worse than you can imagine.
It's violent.
The building is falling apart.
Seeing the third world state of that
jail, maybe even more determined
to run for president
and save our country
from permanent decline.
It is true,
Sheriff,
of course, at the jail
is the focus of a civil rights
probe by the Justice Department.
Ten inmates have died there
so far this year.
The latest death,
I understand, was earlier this week.
I wanted to give you a chance to respond
to all of this.
Well, first, let me let me say that
that's why I was present.
I wanted to make sure
that when these fake accusations came out
about the facility
and the portion that he was
in, I actually was there.
And witnessed the portions
that he actually walked
through very briskly.
So to that end, that, again, much like
everything is
is fake news from that perspective,
And then secondly, in terms of the DOJ
and the Justice Department,
if you go back
and you look at the steps
that we've taken
since I took office and 11611 21,
the focus has been the focus has been
on us, making sure
we've been very transparent,
but also let's face it,
I reached out to the Bureau of Justice,
National Institute
of Corrections
in November of last year
and asked for help.
We work with our board of Commissioners
to really focus on
how do we create better
a better environment.
We inherited this.
There's no mistake about that.
Overcrowding across the country has
really taken precedence
when you look at the number of arrests,
the number of things
that violent arrests in our facility.
So it seems like an anomaly.
The fact that the jail
is a microcosm of our community
as a whole really speaks volumes.
But we are focused
and laser
focused on making sure
we ask for everything we need
and then get our women and men
filling out a sheriff's office,
the tools they need to really combat this
this urgent crisis that we have.
And so even earlier today,
I met with the chairman of Fulton
County Board of Commissioners
so that we could talk about that.
All right.
Well, Sheriff, I appreciate your time.
Thank you so much for coming on
I appreciate it.
Thank you.